like to open up the Judiciary
subcommittee work session on House Bill
533 uh relative to public school human
rights
complaints
um uh for a number of reasons and uh
some members of the subcommittee are not
able to be here
today um but uh representative trip and
I can do um what needs to be done in
that um we do not need a quarum um
because we are just would just be making
a recommendation we're not voting on
anything um although we would rather
have a quarum um and now we do have a
quarum
okay representative lansa has joined us
terrific
um as uh we we asked for um a
subcommittee on this because there was a
a great deal of
um conversation related to the purpose
of this bill why it had come
forward um and
um and there was not a clear
understanding on the part of the
committee so we decided to form a
subcommittee um and this is the
subcommittee
the information that we have received
from a number of people um including by
the way the chair of the education
committee the house of Education
committee is that um
uh given the New Hampshire code of
ethics and code of conduct for
educational professionals and other um
realities that exist in uh state law and
regulation um there were some questions
about the appropriateness of this bill
um in addition the chairman of the
Judiciary Committee has um filed um with
the office of legislative Services um uh
a legislative service request for a
bill dealing somewhat with what I guess
could be
called the non gerain
amendment that had been proposed to this
and um how that will
proceed I don't I don't know um but what
we have before us is the bill
itself um there had been extensive um
testimony on it uh and um I guess what
I'd like to do now is unless the
committee members have another
suggestion is I would like to ask if
there is anybody present who would like
to share with us um their views on this
and I don't know if we want
the
um well let's see do you want to say
something we just here to listen right
now okay okay at any time that you want
to say anything we of course would love
to hear from you but you know there's no
pressure okay so is there anybody else
who would like to share their
views that you don't have
to does anyone on the committee need to
have any further clarification have any
discussion that they would like to have
on
this I would
um my choice would be to hear from you
not hearing from you I would put an idea
on the on the table with the hope that
you will um
share your views with me um or with
everyone who's listening
um I believe the bill was proposed under
certain circumstances a lot of that has
changed we have
[Music]
um I can I personally right now cannot
see any reason to go ahead with this
bill and I do know that representative
cutab who cannot be here today because
of the illness of a
child um has indicated that while she's
always receptive to hearing new
information what she knows at this point
and she's I say this because she's Vice
chair of this subcommittee um is that
she too would favor um an itl on this
bill
uh and so my question now to my two
colleagues is is this
something is this a bill you want to
proceed with in this form or an amended
form or do you believe that there might
be other avenues to address this matter
representative trip do you have any
thoughts on the
subject
um I know the inv for the Department
could you turn on your mic please and
speakers yeah although there not many
people here there might be people
listening I know that uh I know the uh
the uh the investigator for the uh
Department of Education he did uh say
that uh there were numerous instances
where
uh the district after completing a uh
investigation uh the uh Department had
determined that there was a cause to uh
to a follow-up
investigation and uh he uh he said that
there was instances I don't know where
numerous or whatever but uh where the uh
the uh districts
were hesitent to uh
provide details of the in in
investigation that they had conducted
and that
uh he was he was therefore unable to
determine you
know whether there was cause to go
forward with the uh disciplinary action
so uh I thought that
uh that would justify you know the the
request well to
uh
provide uh additional powers to the uh
Department of Education like other
departments have you know which is which
would be the subpoena power so that uh
they could they could do a complete
investigation
uh I
uh I understand that
uh without the subpoena power they're
pretty much just
uh left with the results of the district
investigation so I was
uh I was interested in uh the uh the
department getting the subpoena power so
on once again if you you can't complete
an investigation then uh you don't
really know
what what happened you know
the
uh so it's it's interesting I I have a
somewhat different recollection of of
what was said and um and which is why
I'm very glad you're here and saying
what you're saying because my my
recollection was somewhat different and
that a couple in a couple of ways that
um of course the Attorney General does
have the power power
um to subet in in
appropriate cases but what I heard him
say is that by and large he had been
doing his work for a significant number
of years and has been able to do it um
with no um with no difficulty there
might be in a case here or there some
resistance but he's been able to do all
his work and that he saw this as
something that might have that might
have value in the
future but wasn't
necessarily um needed now and
so I
wonder where we got our
differences our different conclusions
from because I know you're a very
careful listener well I believe I
believe that the gentleman's name is
Richard frell
and uh he said he was the
uh New Hampshire Department education
investigator uh he' received push back
by school districts and information
request uh he said when he went into
look at the
U the records that they had uh taken
during their investigation he was not
allowed to make any
copies
uh
he's that
uh and that uh I
believe he says in in 55 cases uh 10 of
those he got pushed back on and that was
for I believe this year from January to
June so it seemed that
there's
not
well 20% of cases getting pushed back is
sign significant in my mind yeah I think
that is too uh so
uh and he did he did mention that that
the Attorney General is is authorized to
seek you
know information they do have subpena
power but
uh it's I I found it interesting that uh
in going through this the
uh oops excuse me not
me
uh it's it's the it's the schools that
do the initial investigation and
uh I
believe the original bill was
uh was would give the uh people who
initiated the request for investigation
to uh bypass the schools so that the uh
Department of Education can do that is
that
correct well the original Bill all the
original Bill did if I'm
correct
and was to
say um inserting into uh the um a new
paragraph on public school human rights
complaints
the Department of Education May file a
complaint on the behalf of a person
aggrieved by a discriminatory practice
by a school or School District it shall
apply to any retaliation or
discrimination against any person on
whose behalf a complaint has been filed
by the department that was the original
bill as it was introduced yes and
then would you like to explain what
happened next why don't you do that that
because i' like to rely on you as the
expert those are dangerous words well no
it's someone who whose judgment is
important in this yes thank you uh good
morning or good afternoon everyone uh my
name is Anie Malachi I'm the executive
director for the Human Rights Commission
um and so yes it got a little squishy
right so the original bill which is HB
533 was the intent of that bill um that
representative cordelli cordelli is the
prime sponsor of was to add uh a section
into RSA
354a which is the human rights
commission's statute to allow the
commissioner of Education to file a
charge on behalf of an
individual as the conversation continued
um during the initial hearing of HB 53
three if if I remember correctly um two
people from the Department of Education
I believe Diana Fenton and possibly rich
and I can't remember his last name the
investigator gave testimony and
discussed what issues he was having in
subpoena in in uh being able to retrieve
files for his investigations and I
believe that conversation is what uh
created the reason for representative
Lynn to submit the amendment which is
2023-24 a but it is focused in RSA 21
and it talks about subpoena power
relative to the investigations that
Department of Education needs to um
engage Eng in when they're doing their
investigations um and so 533 is very
different from the
amendment there was a lot happening in
the
testimony thank you I think that helps
to clarify the understanding of what's
going on and so we have the initial
bill that says one
thing we have representative lind's
Amendment which as I of course I have
not seen the LSR but as I understand it
um it is an
attempt to address the issue that um Dr
Malachi now
uh
identified
um and which is not in 533
and so that kind of makes
533 as um being an
orphan and I mean I think we should take
care of Orphans and widows but that
doesn't necessarily mean passing
them representative L good to see you
yeah
thank you um I'd like to say just that
um you know after listening to um all
the testimony that was given especially
um the first day that we um heard it um
many representatives from or many not
Representatives pardon me many people um
who had um knowledge of Education who
had been teachers or were current
teachers um all had a lot of concern s
um over this U becoming
um not I don't want to say but could be
politically
motivated and um but um the thing is is
I feel that um after listening
to um what uh Richard frell
said and you know there was question
about um the
teachers teacher not being um you know a
percentage of of them not being um
appropriate and not being good teachers
and um and I felt like
that um you know he was questioned a
couple times and then came back and he
still I mean he didn't come back that
day but a representative who had been U
president in the room said oh yes well
this is what he said on the
outside um I just feel that again by
giving him the subpoena power I don't
think that's the right thing I really
feel um because I actually had a lot of
questions myself and I actually went to
our um um our own ad Miss uh our Miss
superintendent of education and for I
live in Goffstown and just to make sure
I'm understanding everything and so um
so I felt you know there are a lot of
people that do get that uh subpoena
power um throughout the state you know
but
um within this I felt that he was
adequately able to
get um if there if there was cases that
came up he would be able to be provided
and he could sit down and
review any kind of case if he needed to
Richard frell but I don't feel that he
needed to U make a copy of all of those
um things and I again I even asked you
know is this the process that you go
through and um when a a teacher um or a
student or a parent brings this forward
and and they said yes but it's it's done
um in a fairly Manner and this is you
know what we do and um and it's not done
um not done often but it does occur
occasionally but at the same time I just
felt that um with hearing so much
testimony against against this and and
what it was initially brought as a human
rights complaint and then all of a
sudden this was kind of slid in I'm new
but I felt that this was not
appropriate and and um and also I felt
that um the Attorney General's office
um oversees this and also um it I mean
the um the commissioner of Education can
speak to them and that's how that's how
it has to be I don't feel that we um
should have do this you know to give him
that that um right to all of a sudden
have that subpoena privilege um I don't
feel that's the right thing to
do and uh there's just something about
it that doesn't feel right by for me and
um so I would
um agree with
um pardon me Marjorie um I would um
agree with her to itl this I don't feel
that this needs to be um some way or
another it just doesn't feel right and I
don't I feel like this needs to be
ited thank you very much uh Madam chair
for the record Brian Hawkins Nea New
Hampshire uh we testified uh on both the
original Bill 533 as well as the the uh
non-gain Amendment um and um I think to
what was mentioned earlier um there is
going to be a discussion in the upcoming
session around the merits of whether the
Department of Education ought to have
subpoena power uh I saw the LSR title
from representative uh
Lynn um but this is a very different
bill that as you said you have before
you uh with respect to Bringing uh human
rights complaints uh and
so uh I think when it comes time for the
hearing on whatever bill number is going
to be assigned to representative lind's
bill we can have the debate on the
merits of of whether the department
should have subpoena power Andor any
kind of um guard rails that may be
associated with that but I think the
vehicle you have before you is a very
different matter and and that was one
that obviously we opposed during the
session so those would be the only
comments I would add right
now thank you
um thank you very much is anybody have
any
questions uh representative I'm not
representative I'm
sorry um chair Matt Malachi could I ask
you another question if we were to
pass
533 as it is
written um do you have the
capacity to handle all any complaints
that would come from that um thank you
for the question um
the the it it's not so much in terms of
capacity but this would be an
unprecedented power given to another
agency So currently uh the only agency
that could file a charge with the
commission would be the Attorney
General's office so this would be giving
equal status to the Department of
Education with the Department of Justice
in this particular matter um the other
element is for us when someone files a
charge it's not an anonymous charge
someone has to come in and whether it's
phone or however but there's a person
associated with the charge so um I
believe um attor Assistant Attorney
General lock went into additional
definitions or explanations I should say
in terms of well what happens next so if
this is an anonymous charge and the
Department of Education is bringing this
charge how who is attached to it who's
representing that person does the
Department of Education become their
attorney their spokesperson um when do
we who are we investigating what what
are we investigating on behalf of this
particular individual um and so there
were a lot of issues that uh this uh
that HB 533 would bring to the Forefront
which would be very complicated and um
if it means that if the Department of
Education has a has a complaint or
something they should be sending folks
to the commission to actually file the
complaint um if there are any additional
issues then certainly between our
attorney in the civil Bureau of the doj
and the department of education's
attorney I'm certain that those two
entities could have conversations to
figure something out without giving this
extraordinary power and so it makes it
very difficult for us to ascertain um
who we would be interviewing when the
charge is taken um who is attached to
the charge how do we go forward with
providing um evidence G who are we
Gathering evidence from so it's not as
simple as just giving us some
information and we go on our way there
has to be a person that's attached to it
so those are the issues that become very
difficult If This Were to
pass thank
you well I want to I want to apologize
for uh uh conflating The subpoena
Amendment with the original bill because
uh it does change it
entirely the um and and I remember that
uh uh part of the rationale for the uh
for the bill when given by uh
representative cordelli was that uh you
know the the uh as as you said the the
people that were uh asking for you know
the ability of the Department of
Education to uh file the
uh grievance is that it you know uh
we're we're going to be doing it
anonymously so it's
uh it's one of these things that it's
complicated uh but just because it's
complicated doesn't mean that you know
something shouldn't be done about it U
you know because if the if the student
feels that uh they were not
uh taken care of properly you know and
in the schools uh did not
uh did
not properly take appropriate action
take appro appropriate action you know
then uh it it seems that there should be
a a means for students you know
who that they shouldn't have to suffer
through you know the schools doing
whatever it is are doing that you know
that are
uh thank you
anyhow can't find the words no I mean
we're all you know we're all on This
Together We want to do the best the best
that can be done for uh the children in
this state y we certainly want to make
sure that the that the school system is
focused on meeting the children's needs
we want to make sure that the teachers
are focused on meeting the children's
needs no one disagrees with that um how
you go about doing
it is different
and just
having the department be able to to drop
a complaint on the desk at human
relations commission and expect them to
go and solve these the complicated
problems of public education doesn't
make any sense so in terms of I don't
think anybody thinks it makes any sense
in terms of the bill original
bill it's one thing in terms of the
proposed
amendment
um I think that by chairman Lynn going
ahead and filing an
LSR he himself was
sending a
signal that a better way to handle this
is instead of with an non gerain
amendment is to have um which everyone
agreed was a non-gain Amendment which is
why we had to have the hearing in the
first place was to have
um a new bill come in a hearing discuss
it and act on
it if we were to decide to itl the bill
I think we would have to want to make
sure that in our
um report I almost said blur but I
didn't in our report
um we make clear that in no way are we
minimizing the importance of meeting the
needs of children
if we took that approach are you
comfortable with that representative yes
it's one of these things where uh I I
agree that the the the current bill is
uh is inadequate it doesn't
uh provide the relief
that that I I believe representative
Celli thought it did and and it wasn't
you know the proper vehicle for
uh some soling this problem you know so
I I agree with you if if there's a if we
can provide a recommendation that says
that uh you know yes there is a problem
but uh we believe that this is not the
solution and that uh you
know a better solution is being recom is
being
developed well technically speaking we
do have a quarum because there are three
of us here out of the five on uh uh who
are on our subcommittee because it's
couta Paige Lan trip and me but because
there are only
three what I would like to suggest if
and if the two of you agree is that we
don't take a vote but instead
say
summarize our our conclusions and then
ask the committee to
vote that's a great idea is that okay
yes I I just and with just three of us I
I
feel a little hesitant to take a formal
vote and put that kind of pressure on
the full
committee um you
know but um if that's okay with you so
that would mean when we come back on the
eth um in our work
session we would have a chance then
present to the committee why we are
making this suggestion that we're making
rather than presenting a mo a formal
motion no is that okay suggestion
recommendation same thing well it except
somehow if we went in with a vote they
would have to accept or reject the vote
and I just i' like to have a bigger yeah
a bigger group yeah but
do you have another suggestion yeah you
have a different suggestion no I don't
okay so you're okay with that
representative Smith could I add
something you'd like um to to answer
your question representative um you were
your concern was for students who may
have an issue of discrimination and them
uh whether or not they were able to come
to the commission and and that was the
concern um the way the law is stated
right now they can and if retaliation is
something that they that the student or
the parent is concerned about um
retaliation is already in our statute
and that is against the law now do
people follow the law that's a really
good question but if there's some form
of retaliation that that student is
facing that can be added to the charge
and we can do that investigation to
Encompass all of that so this particular
Bill all it does is take the take the um
ability that that is already present for
a student or their parent or Guardian to
file a charge and add it to the
Department of Education specifically the
commissioner um it still doesn't answer
the question of well who is the person
filing the charge if the Department of
Education is filing it who are they
filing it on behalf of if that person
wants to be anonymous we have nothing to
investigate because we don't have a
person to interview and Witnesses Etc um
so it's just like if you go to the
police station you could let the police
know that something happened but if
you're not willing to to sign some sort
of affidavit saying you witnessed it
then there's not they they're put on
notice but there's not much they can do
so that's where it gets a little weird
um and represent representative Smith
you asked about um charges I think so in
2019 when K through2 public education
was added a wild guess here I think we
may have had between then and now maybe
there's been five or six charges filed
with us so I don't think there would be
an inordinate amount of charges filed um
and certainly back to subpoena power um
if there was some issue and we needed an
injunction or something we have the
ability to have that conversation with
the Department of Justice to seek an
injunction on behalf of of a student
where something is really you know going
wrong there
so okay so I think maybe we're okay on
this I believe so are you comfortable I
representative lens are you comfortable
yes okay anything else that
anyone would like to add if not then
I'll sum up by saying we will present to
the full committee on um November 8th
our recommendation that the bill um be
declared be voted on itl and that um we
acknowledge the existence of a pending
um LSR on the nonchain
amendment everybody okay with that
agreement that's good yes okay well we
did that in record time thank you for
coming and I call an end to this session
thanks very
much
glad to see you Judy know we missed you
last yes I know I know I wish I would
have been able to come yeah all the
judges were I know they were really yeah
it was helpful to hear a lot of stuff
huh yeah yeah
yeah yeah but I'm I'm uh reading through
some of the information that oh that
they um put in there so it and it was it
was also show yes yeah so I'll read I'll
try to listen to that as
well
yeah